welcome to the circle it's the cycle of
life
the cycle of life the cycle of life the
cycle of life
cycle of life the cycle of life oh boy
are you guys in for a treat cycle of
life
currently sitting at a respectable 2.8
on imdb
this has to be one of the worst horror
movies i've ever seen
[Music]
so sit right down and open your eye
holes because you're in for a halloween
treat
this is some multi-dimensional kung fu
we're getting into here boy
meet greg he's decided to take his
daughter samantha on a camping trip
where they're viciously attacked by a
bear
and the production didn't have any money
to hire a bear or create a cgi one so
they had to tell us in dialogue
looks like a bear attack somehow the
daughter survives the attack completely
unscathed and is able to get help from a
nearby cult
well we don't know they're a cult yet
but uh we'll we'll get to that so greg
wakes up all bloody and bandaged with
two women hovering over him kinda like
my saturday morning correct
that was a lie and naturally he asks
where his daughter is
oh samantha she's in bubble class yes we
get to see bubble class in action but
samantha refuses to take off this creepy
ass mask and i'm like how do you blow
bubbles with that thing can we also
recognize the random kid mannequins just
chilling around
you'd think greg would be like hey
what's with all the mannequins but nope
they're just um
there there's also no acknowledgement
that greg was just attacked by a bear
and you know maybe he should go to a
hospital
so the girls are excited to introduce
greg to their leader matthew and honest
to god i'm
just gonna let this scene play out
unedited this is the dialogue
so so so
yeah so
so so you'd think greg would want his
daughter and maybe go to a hospital but
instead he takes a nap and wakes up in
the middle of the night
to find the cult members eating someone
alive he rushes to save his daughter but
when he can't find her nor his cell
phone he does what any of us would do in
this situation
and goes to bed and when he wakes up the
next morning instead of looking for his
kid he decides to find his car
real father of the year material
unfortunately his keys are back in the
house with those cannibals so
he has to go back in there retrieve them
and escape with his daughter
but when he actually gets her she's like
i hate you that's funny
you're [ __ ] up buddy yeah she's been
here for half a day after surviving a
bear attack and is already like
[ __ ] you dad i want to go to bubble
class you know
bubble class so he has to go after his
daughter once again but runs across a
mannequin
copy of himself i hate when that happens
now i don't know who keeps moving these
mannequins around it's never really
explained and i have
no idea how they got this replica of his
shirt but hey let's just go with it
so the mannequin holds up a mirror up to
greg where he is somehow
transported to a cabin to meet the
entity known as percy stevens yes the
evil demon thing in this story is called
percy stephen and greg here pleads for
his life i need to live it is imperative
that i live cannot die okay then he's
brought back to reality when two of the
girls decide to throw
fishing hooks at him
look at those rods it's like what i'd
give my four-year-old niece anyway
obviously those dinky fish hooks aren't
going to keep him in line oh the puns
are terrible
so skye comes along and straight up
nails a harpoon through his face
and kills him we're a third through the
movie and our main character has died so
the screenwriter is like oh [ __ ] we
should probably introduce some new
characters
meet gabriella james and grady none of
whom have any connection to the guy we
just spent a half hour following james
and gabriella have hired grady to
infiltrate the circle and bring their
friend rebecca
one of its members back all i know is he
has my wife
and i want her back
okay if this is how you treat the guy
who's gonna bring back your wife i don't
think things are gonna go over really
well greedy is like that one guy from
jaws who knows like
everything that they're going up against
black guy like a doll's
he spends 10 minutes telling them all
about the history of the circle's
founder percy stevens which has no
impact on the story whatsoever
yeah percy here's a guy who trained
combat elephants in malaysia
a renowned theater director in austria
new zealand national chess champion
three years running
he was a world-class spelunker at age
14. master puppeteer ventriloquist
hypnotist spiritualist and this was
all before he was recruited as a special
ops diver for the us navy in 1950.
meanwhile sam finds members of the
circle eating her dad she runs away and
skye runs after her stabbing mannequins
in the children's cabin
and here's sam with her masterful hiding
oh i should have mentioned that earlier
in the film the circle picked up a new
member named
tina everyone this is tina i picked her
up on the overpass
she's actually an informant working for
grady her code name
is fire cat fire cat shut up and answer
my question
what's wrong who's fire cat she made the
unfortunate mistake of calling grady
from the math room and the others
overhear her call so they do what they
always do and make a mannequin of her
[Music]
with this informant dead grady and the
team have to head in blind
if you're restless stick your thumb up
your ass oh sorry that wasn't the clip
planes change i planned for that too
impromptu dancing around the mannequins
so when these guys get off their mobile
home i guess that's what you drive when
you're staging a kidnapping
i'm not plotting about mitzvah here this
is kidnapping grady immediately says
he's going off on his own
yep it's the stereotypical horror movie
trope of splitting everyone up james
says he has to use the outhouse and i'm
like
why don't you just use the one in the rv
why do you choose this creepy ass one
oh [ __ ] sorry wait
what
like how they even got that mannequin
ready in time they would have had to
know he was coming but it's never
explained there's also this backstory
that
james and gabriella used to be a thing
but that too
isn't explored no you hit on me
i was drunk and you are the one who told
her now look at where we are
so grady enters the main cult house and
just starts like tossing [ __ ] and
spilling tea everywhere
he also has this habit of when people
ask him something he
won't answer it twice it's a facade
what nothing smoking mirrors
what nothing grady ends up regrouping
with gabriella and reveals that he
actually grew up with the circle his mom
and him used to be members but for some
reason he doesn't know how a lot of the
stuff in the circle works like for
example the outhouse door is a portal to
the shack in the distance
grady and gabriella go into the shack
then somehow get stuck in this upside
down world where grady tells her the key
to escaping is to do
nothing the thing we have to do is
nothing
wow this is gonna be an exciting movie
for the last half hour we watch them do
jack [ __ ] so james is now with this
spirit of percy stevens who has taken
over the body of tina aka firecat we all
still following along
good and honestly he makes a great plea
as to why he should go to heaven
oh look i did the thing i did the church
thing
sam comes to save grady but gabriella
can't come with them apparently if you
aren't or weren't a member of the circle
your brain explodes if you try to leave
but later she gets out somehow i
it's never explained so grady gives her
his guns even though he's the one going
back out into the real world which kinda
makes no sense
sam takes gritty to her dead father but
it's just the mannequin of him
sam leads grady to percy's cabin where
he confronts the spirit of percy stevens
we learn that percy was eaten by a shark
and somehow became the greatest entity
the universe has ever known
yeah it's kind of starting to derail
here she shows him a picture of himself
as a child and
meanwhile the other cult members have
dressed james up as a scuba diver i
think it has something to do with them
trying to recreate percy's shark attack
death but
who cares at this point sky just ends up
shooting him with a harpoon until
they're held at near point blank range
by gabriella
and instead of you know putting your
hands up and trying to talk things out
they
do this
wait let's see that again look at the
cgi gunshot oh
god now i don't know what the hell
happened here but look at the background
her scenes were clearly shot at night
time while the others were shot
during the day with james dead the
spirit of percy takes over him i guess
it kinda works that whoever was the last
one to die
the spirit takes over and out of nowhere
a younger version of grady just starts
railing on him but don't worry everyone
sam comes in and beats the crap out of
him
but with all these deaths happening so
suddenly percy has somehow morphed into
his real form
and turns into a marionette because okay
he's pretty easy to escape from like
he's just on strings and stuff
but grady doesn't make it out now sam is
like turned into some terminator kid
she stabs skye in the head and tries to
kill rebecca but gabriella shoots
rebecca with the trank gun before any
more damage can be done
now are you all ready for the big twist
when grady was taken by percy he somehow
took
over sam's body we know this because
throughout the film we see grady using
eye drops and in this final scene where
gabrielle escapes with sam salmon
rebecca is tied up sam puts eye drops in
her eyes
ooh spooky or she just has allergies and
the film ends
thank god with sam wearing that creepy
mask as the rv
motors away now if you're looking for
something to scare you this halloween
don't watch this there's always hubie
halloween
thanks for watching everyone if you
liked the video check out my other think
story takedowns
be sure to like subscribe and share and
give me a follow on twitter and
instagram at think story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much